with the Utrecht student choir u s
c are members
suspended to circulating 1 banga list
concerns 1 powerpoint with the name greek presentation
year 23 it contains about 30 women from UVSV
the Utrecht female student association
that their photos are shared
addresses telephone numbers
we are shocked and we do not want that
the women are judged with sentences like
has horny tits or is nice and raunchy
the USC board says they are ashamed
the prosecution is about investigations
criminal offenses have been committed
the parents of the
students on the list have 1
lawyer engaged and file declarations
it is not the first time that such a list has been circulated
at the Gronings
the student association vindicat
did that happen in 2016
even after that 1 member was suspended